just say something about my rewards this
is a sentence that you do not very often
hear from people in Washington but it's
really important not to exaggerate how
important I was in the scheme of this
and and I think one of the big ways that
in fact history gets Mis written is that
people inevitably who talk about these
things always end up overstating what
their own role was now my role was so
very small that even if I overstate it
I'll still be on they be able to be
considerably modest about it but so I
with that caveat when the president
delivered the axis of evil speech it was
not it was not because I told him to do
it it's not because any speechwriter
told him to do it we work for him he
gives us the broad outlines of what he
wants to say and we then help him to say
it as effectively as memorably as
persuasively as we can and and if you
broadly disagree with what he's doing
then it's your job to go but it's not
your job not to deliver it I mean that's
it's his administration it never
occurred to me however when the
president made the decision to speak so
strongly in particular about the Iranian
piece which was a surprise to me I
didn't think he would do it but when he
made that decision to go ahead and to do
it and actually named Iran as one of the
countries he was concerned about never
occurred to me that you would do such
strong language that having a clear plan
in mind about what you intended to do
and I I would agree I mean to speak to
use strong language where you don't have
a strong plan is always a reckless
mistake and when you look back on what
our policy toward Iran has been over the
past half dozen years it probably was a
mistake to speak so forcefully because
the United States looks ineffective that
we have said something we have said in
2002 that an Iranian nuclear weapon was
absolutely unacceptable and here we are
in 2008 pretty close to a decision to
accept it and that looks that's
humiliating that we should not have we
should we should either we should have
avoided one we should have we should
have chosen to
frontwards or match your policy to our
words
you